wow this is electric let's kick it off  welcome to the rock and roll  [Applause]  [Music]  what makes for longevity consistent  quality over time and plus headbands  SMA people feel better about themselves  thank you Pat was my hero an immediate  icon it has been an incredible ride  Eminem is the best selling hip-hop  artist this is crazy thank you  their sweet dreams were forged in the  furnace of Faith music is in our souls  We Still Rock the Lionel shows up  everyone gets happy rock and roll is not  a color it's a vibe  Carly Simon Springs and sophistication  are Peerless Judas priests are the  definitive metal band everybody's  welcome that there is what heavy metal  is all about Dolly part I figure I'm  gonna be in the rock and roll Hall of  Fame I'm gonna have to earn it  [Applause]  [Music]  was rock and roll good night everybody  [Music]